I'm joined today by Matan field who is
architect and co-founder of dow stack
we've been talking about the dow more
generally we've also talked about dow
stack specifically before so it's great
to have Matan here for people who don't
know Matan because this I find that one
of the most complex things about talking
about these projects is actually
explaining them in a way that the
average person sort of understands what
it is that you are doing let's maybe
start with the Dow what do we mean when
we say the Dow and that's Dao right not
do W is in the Dow Jones Industrial
Average of the United States
what is the Dow for people who don't
know high living thanks thanks for
having me here so thou is the acronym
for decentralized autonomous
organization it's a it's a sort of a new
form of organizing people into Co action
to greater larger large-scale action
justice organization or companies do the
difference though is that while
companies are usually closed structures
closed a hierarchical structures with a
management a vertical management
structure decentralized organization is
accordingly
in direct coordination of people that
are coordinated by code by rules that
are set on the blockchain and that are
inherently open that anyone could
participate in those organizations and
so these are generally the central
service organizations and and and
generally the belief is that the central
stern organization can be can grow into
much much larger scale than companies or
corporations they do this is super
interesting because you know if you
start reading about even going back to
the modernization of humans right Homo
sapiens one of the big distinguishing
factors between humans and nonhumans is
the ability to work together in large
numbers but in sort of flexible ways
right so like bees can work together in
very very large numbers but only in very
narrow senses there are other animal
species that can work together more
flexibly solving some basic problems
but in very small numbers so humans are
unique in that we are able to work
together in very large numbers and also
flexibly however usually usually not
always that does require a hierarchical
structure a centralized structure of
command of sorts and that's often how
you know everything from militaries to
companies are organized if I understand
correctly one of the interesting
elements of what Dow is doing and
ultimately we'll talk about what Dow Dow
stack is also doing is the idea to
enable humans to work together in large
numbers and flexibly but in a
decentralized way that's a nothing but
perfect distinction so these two access
that you mentioned the size of the
coordination and the flexibility of the
Carnation is exactly you know the map of
the world of the history and and we have
never approved we have never been able
to approach the deep upper-right hands
of that map so the largest scale and
most flexibly so the internet for
example is a coordination of the largest
amount number of people on the planet a
global scale but it's coordination
around very specific topic just
distribution of information and indeed
in order to kind of like stretch it to
large scale and flexibly you know we
needed more and more rigid structures
such as Army for example army is the
largest scale with pretty flexibly but
the cost of that is that the
effectiveness the efficiency of large
very very rigid structures is getting
lower lower as they grow up and the
decentralized nature of the organization
what it promises is the ability to probe
the ability the ability to coordinate
people into the largest scale to the
global scale and yet remain most
flexibly and effective at the same time
so it's it's if you want it's a new kind
of Internet but that can do can
coordinate people for about and just
about anything so let's now talk about
Dow stack what is it that your project
is looking to do building on this
concept of Dow
the most basic level doll stock is the
technology to enable dowse to
self-organize to enable dowse to exist
so if i said that instead of
hierarchical rigid structures there are
rules around which people play or
coordinate and those rules are encoded
on the blockchain then dow stock is you
know in the in the most simplistic
manner is the engine for those rules in
a much more detail we can go we can get
into it if you wish but in much more
details it's many elements that compose
those rules and improve them over time
by the end of the days is the engine of
the rules for large-scale coordination
the centralized coordination of the
blockchain well I want to talk more
about the specifics I think for most of
our audience the bigger picture idea is
what what will be more interesting than
so much the underlying technology which
of course some of our audience can can
read about directly in the white paper
so I mean to get us deeper into the
discussion there's a lot here you talked
about decentralization when we talk
about decentralization oftentimes that's
heard potentially as a sort of
individual collectivism which sounds
sort of like an oxymoron but in a way it
does sort of apply here
can you talk maybe a little bit about
the specific applications or maybe some
use cases that most people could relate
to where doubt stack would be used sure
so let me give you three examples three
canonical examples so one example would
be you know the the usual idea of
collaboration so just as companies you
know they coordinate maybe hundred maybe
tens or hundreds or even thousands of
people to build something together so
you build product to produce something
in the same way the centralization can
be the coordination of hundreds of
thousands of let's say for example
creators or developers or designers that
all together build huge applications
that they can solve it totally a totally
new kind of questions that are not now
unsolvable because they can coordinate
many more producers around those
problems so producing for example
producing of code that's one sort of
application which
already very there is a high demand for
that so that already there are large
scale collaborations around mostly
around blockchain projects which are
open sourcing in nature and they have
serious problems which are yet to be
resolved and in order to such as for
example the scalability of blockchain
that's one of maybe one of the biggest
problems and in order to resolve them
you need a large lot much larger scale
of coordination of developers so that's
one example
a totally different example is about for
example management of assets so let's
you know you can have hundreds or
millions of millions people coordinating
shared assets together for example I
think that may be one of the interesting
use case will be insurance so instead of
having million people insured by a
company you can have those minos people
insuring each other
in a big decentralized insurance network
which would be way way more effective
and with higher alignment of interests
then today's insurance companies and and
maybe a third example is the round
curation so we are not very often using
that word but it's actually we are we're
all familiar with that idea so for
example Google itself is they in a
curation agent engine for website so it
tells you what is a good or less good
website or less more more or less
relevant TripAdvisor is a curation for
for travels and hotels and booking.com
and Yelp is a curation engine for
restaurants and so on so forth and we
already are in the phase in history
where we are using crowd creation where
people curate because there's a lot of
information that is carried by people
but isn't but there's no effective way
to enable that at large scale so imagine
millions of people coordinated with
those decentralized curation networks
and by that exchange information about
quality of basically anything you can
think of much more effectively than
today's applications I'd like I'd love
to get your thoughts on another area
where Dow could be applied which is
financial markets right I've talked to a
lot of people about possibilities
between Dow and financial markets and in
general and financial market
particularly in the United States
there's a sort of distrust of the
difference in information that different
players have an assumed manipulation
that's taking place and the top-down
hierarchy is concerning to a lot of
people so on the one hand I've read
position papers from individuals who say
listen automating and but using
algorithms through Dow projects to
control financial markets in a different
way than we're doing it now is very very
exciting the counter that I've heard to
that and I'm curious as to your thoughts
on this Matan is that once you take
something like a financial market and
you allow algorithms to make decisions
that that carries with it a crazy amount
of risk in terms of for the individual
participant in that financial market do
you have a strong opinion one way or the
other on that so let me let me let me
let me first ask first attend something
that you mentioned something else that
you mentioned yeah which is important to
understand the concept so firstly
whenever I say Dow by the way let me let
me also distinct Dow from da you know
I'll get back to that but whenever I say
Dow I mean that there is a certain
collective decision process so let me
give you a counter example so when you
talk about the market a market place it
can be ecommerce market placing the
token exchange market place whenever you
talk about a market place where the base
interaction is peer-to-peer I buy you
sell whenever you have that kind of
structure there is no collective
decision-making it's just in
peer-to-peer interactions so these I
will not call them dowse and call them
peer-to-peer marketplaces now of course
peer-to-peer magnifies can also be those
for example they can collectively decide
about the rules of the game if they want
you know the peer-to-peer game if they
want to it actually have true actually
examples of this sort that we're good
that are going live in the in there in
the next few months but when I when I
purely think about now I think about
collecting the scene making so if you so
if I will apply
now into financial market I will think
about it more as the kind of the
dissenters insurance that I mentioned or
maybe at the central investment fund so
maybe you know 10,000 vistors our
co-managing or traders are co-managing
shared assets and then there is a
dissenter as decision making process
to make so that's that's the that's the
you know one comment and the second
comment regarding algorithms then it's
important to note that I mean the the
the Dow is kind of like hybrid between
the Machine and the dividend they and
the human so there is the machine the
blockchain that kind of like
algorithmically collects the inputs for
many many agents but then there is the
human input into that and it goes in
also in the way that the protocol the
rules that people play around also
include the rules to change the rules so
so in that sense if there is any danger
you know for having not-not-not
optimizer or maybe dangerous rules then
there is also encoded in the rules the
rules to change the rules so that would
be like know the simplest answer to this
concern
Matan in the limited time we have left
I'd love to talk a little bit about the
coin what is the purpose of the coin
what does it do and sort of where are
you in the token sale right so so I
haven't you know I told you what the Dow
is but I haven't when you you know we
can ask like why don't we have them
already so the answer is that there is a
really hard problem of making it down
and the problem is that when you speak
about collective decision-making you
kind of like say consensus like everyone
agree about something yeah right but at
the same time you want to have a you
know effective organization so maybe you
have million people coordinate you know
collaborating and you know maybe they do
million actions a day but you don't
really want million people to look at
each and every action right it's
complete completely not scalable
completely not ineffective so this is a
conundrum of Sandra's governance how do
you build the governance protocol rules
with which 1 million people can on one
hand have consensus about
each and everything but the same time
not really have a consensus and this is
like a tension and the way that we solve
that is introducing a new kind of
consensus protocol we call them
holographic consensus we won't get into
that probably in this in this short
interview yes but that involves certain
machinery certain prediction game in
which people can place predictions
economical predictions about a spate of
proposals fate of decisions inside
organizations and this prediction game
on one hand is super critical for the
enabling of large-scale collective
decision-making at the same time that
that prediction game is being run with
our token with the gent oaken so the
gent talkin if you want is the is the
engine token for if you want gathering
the collective attention and basically
it's it's managed via this prediction
game that is enabling large-scale a
consensus to take place so this is the
the token utility it's it's a critical
element in large-scale governance in
terms of our our crowd say we make we're
basically ran a private sale for a few
months now we've finished that private
sale we have we are now running
literally now running a community
presale it's not it still has like maybe
36 hours to go but it's already the cap
is already reached and next week we'll
have the third phase of a public sale
but basically out of 30 million dollars
that we wanted to raise we've already
raised somewhere around 27 where is the
best place for people to learn not only
about Dow stack the project but also the
ICO so the website I think is the best
well two places the website and the
telegram group but then the terror group
is also linked from the website and vice
versa excellent and we are linking to
both in the description to the YouTube
video Matan field architect and
co-founder of dow stack thanks so much
for talking to me about this today thank
you David thanks a lot